can you survive this prime minister
is the party over
the question we've been asking for days
but a verdict delayed maybe until next
week
the prime minister heading for the gates
of downing street in heavily guarded
convoy
entering the commons purposeful but
exposed parliament is where danger comes
from his own side
but for all the jeers in this
place serious questions too not least
about whether the pm has always told the
truth standing at this dispatch box
the minister of code
says that ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
does the prime minister believe that
applies to him
prime minister mr speaker of course but
let me tell the house uh that i think
he's inviting a question about an
investigation which is uh you know mr
speaker i can't uh comment and uh uh on
which i would choose as a lawyer mr
speaker will know that i that i can't
comment on and what i am focused on is
delivering the fastest recovery of any
european
the lawyer ready to interrogate the
detail deep breath and a sip of water
will the pm publish sugray's report in
full
on the 8th of december he told this
house i will place a copy of the report
in the library of the house of commons
that means the full report
not parts of the report not a summary of
the report not an edited copy
so can the prime minister confirm that
he will publish the full sue grey report
as he receives it
mr speaker what i can tell him is that
we've got to leave the report to the
independent uh investigators he knows uh
and of course uh when i receive it i of
course i will do exactly what i said but
for so many of his own backbenchers
support for weeks has hinged them being
able to read the sugray report in full
we just wanted the fullest amount of
details let's get on
gosh i mean how long is it going to take
to get this report i'm going to wait
until the report is published which i
will study carefully that's a notable
lack of
confidence in the prime minister from
yours do you have confidence in boris
johnson i'm
not going to say any more to you than
i've said ultimately this is why the sue
grey report and the conclusion of the
police inquiry matter obviously we have
to make sure that we have the absolute
best government we have the best
leadership team in place as is possible
so whether you know sue grey report or
the metropolitan police report and due
to come out is that we have to take all
those things seriously
every day between now and publication
downing street can try and ensure as
softer landing as possible in this place
but judgement day still awaits sam
coates sky news westminster